[Music]
hello there
how good was that event you can be
honest now how many times have you
replayed it
i've been through it 11 times now
testing out theories and downright
wasting time to annoy agent jonesy
today we are breaking down everything
that happened over the course of that
event in the hopes of finding new clues
to the story
and a few easter eggs too if you're new
around these parts please click
subscribe it's totally free
and if you come back regularly have a
think about using my creator code
it's adamaru if you'd be so kind so sit
your butt down for 10 minutes and let's
find
28 things you missed in the zero point
crisis
the first thing many of us noticed was
all thanks to subtitling
during the opening cinematic agent jones
spoke to two characters
the woman on the phone from last season
and the hench guy in the seven
neither character is referred to by name
but those with subtitles switched on
knew straight away the woman who ordered
jonesy back into the loop
is named dr sloane we still don't know
what she looks like just yet
but we do know she has a doctorate in
something meaning she's educated to a
high standard
now that johnsy has switched sides he
completely destroys his communication
with dr sloane
and that is the moment agent jonesy has
officially left
the imagined order the second character
johnsy meets is the foundation
which may sound like a new rap group
ready to drop the album of the year
but as always the names of the seven all
mean something the visitor was the first
of the seven to travel to see us in
chapter one
the scientists took the visitors work
and evolved it using
well science and the paradigm okay she
doesn't have much law yet
i personally believe she is singularity
from season nine
but that is not law yet and i get
shouted out every time i bring it up
so i won't go there and now we have the
foundation
the word foundation is used in two ways
first in construction
as the bottom layer of something there
to keep everything else in place
and the second meaning of foundation is
an underlying principle
you know like helping old ladies cross
the road
by smashing both meanings together we
can surmise the foundation is the leader
of the seven and is pivotal to the story
as he represents the beginning of
something we'll likely find out in
two chapters from now and right now he's
literally holding the foundations of
reality together
in a giant easter egg at the end of the
scene for a split second
the camera travels through a strand of
time by pausing the footage we can see
this
maybe the future of fortnite this is
likely suggesting a version of reality
in which realistic graphics are used in
fortnite instead of the cartoony ones we
have right now
if you need more detail the rocks are
taken from a ps5
tech demo for the new unreal engine epic
is implementing
maybe one day we will see fortnite have
two filters
one for photo realism and one classic i
have no idea what these people are doing
here but this emote is a callback to the
praise the sun gesture
in dark souls to indicate a warrior of
sunlight
this is getting a little too serious
let's change things up
oh and i know for 90 plus days we've
been all attempting to name
this thing that jonesy holds i called it
a shard of the zero point
other people called it a portal gun well
we can clear it up right now
if we keep our distance when it's time
to pick it up the object will pop up on
screen
and now we know the exact name the
portal device
simple but effective and we also know
it's officially a legendary tier item
let's back up a little earlier jones
jumps from the battle bus to catch the
zero point shard
sorry i mean the portal device take a
note of the fall damage he takes
99 one more meter of fall damage
and this story would have been over
before it began
let's all remember that jondy clutched
this on one health
what a true legend we've touched on
jonesy's attire in the past but let's
quickly pinpoint everything we can see
here
we can now confirm his headband is his
own tie
i originally thought this was ryu's
headband but we now know jonesy's right
hand
is the sparring mitt ryu uses in street
fighter the tattoo on his left arm
is the gi joe symbol likely given to him
by snake eyes
by the way snake eyes will fight batman
next month in fortnite
that is not a joke the chest plate and
headset are taken from his visit to the
aliens universe
and the character vazquez the animal
silhouette is the sign of the
mandalorian race from star wars and the
arrows are taken from the walking dead
crossover there's also other influences
especially batman for some reason as
jones has created his own utility belt
and spiked foram gauntlet
johnsy has been acquiring upgrades all
season and this will continue
into season six
there's a few movie references during
the scene the t800s approaching from
distance is a call back to the future
war scene in the terminator 2 movie
complete with purple lasers
and there's a second t2 reference as the
truck smashes through the bridge wall
overhead
mimicking the chase scene from the same
movie as jonesy runs forward
mancake attempts to decapitate him this
brings in kratos to battle the butter
barn legend you may think this is a
pointless shout out
but if you remember back when kratos was
revealed he scared mancake so much
he ran away as a call back to that first
meeting now mancake holds his
ground and fights kratos another one of
these can be found later in the trailer
when master chief appeared fish stixx
was the first to meet him
and now they are fighting side by side
tiny pieces of character development in
only a few seconds
impressive work epic games ggs one thing
baffles me in this trailer
if we pause at the man cake scene there
is a huge tomato
town pizza pit head in the sand i mean
it's gargantuan
likely a throwaway easter egg but just
in case this may come up in the future
know that this was the day we saw it
first as the trailer rolls on lara croft
can be spotted
a little bit too early to be a season
six character that would also explain
why jones wears her boots
she may have been intended to be a
season five hunter rather than a season
six crossover character
she's not joining in with the fight
she's just running in a straight line
goal lara pili gets a regular call out
to indicate he and jones are
indeed friends even after he was eaten
by a jones snapshot to survive
into season nine but we don't talk about
that
pili is back oh no he isn't for a split
second in the game a police chase could
be seen
this had me confused mainly because
police vehicles were removed from
fortnite in support of the black lives
matter movement
this shot here shows the first cop car
in fortnite since
june 2020
[Music]
jones is prevented from reaching the
zero point by many battle pass
characters
like mousels and tientina from season
two can we pause for a moment to give
tina the props she deserves
she lands in the perfect superhero pose
after leaping from the rocket perfection
also for a split second the hybrid skin
is shown it's not there for very long
and the thing to keep in mind here is
that these were evolved from
eggs and right now in fortnite there are
new eggs to be discovered
finally jonesy reaches the zero point
and we see how the portal device is
calibrated
by turning the orb it appears he can
choose a time and reality zone
but in this instance he's thinking
bigger and is not teleporting himself to
that zone
he's teleporting that zone here in a
repeat of the opening events of season
four
and season x of chapter one a meteorite
containing one of the seven
arrives luckily we don't have to deal
with a crater bigger than your mum
instead it's just a tiny little divot
the foundation enters but unlike the
scientist and the visitor
the foundation's pod is huge he can
freely walk in there whereas the others
were tightly packed in
someone needs to review the class system
in the seven also a thing of note is
that the same molten rock is found on
all three meteors we've seen so far
and look at the colour of that pod even
though the foundation is a different
colour scheme
the pod keeps the original colours set
by the og visitor
almost three years ago i began looking
over the armor of the foundation
it looks to be from multiple time
periods if you think of it of like how
we upgraded mando's best car steal last
season
i think this helps understand the
materials used on the foundation's
attire and then one spot on the
foundation's chest
felt reminiscent i'd seen it before and
we'd actually seen it twice
the camera shutter door has been used at
the volcano event when we opened the
vault
and we'd also seen it last season too
the same effect was used to open the
zero triangulation point at the io
bunker
each time we've seen the mark like this
it represents a changing in reality
but now i have a question why does the
foundation have a port
near his heart the day we find out is
going to be a sad day
next we were hit with the law we now
know 100
that jonesy and the foundation know each
other there was not a single moment of
hesitation from the leader of the seven
and jones knew right away he wouldn't be
trusted
this tells us they have met before and
judging by the foundation's aggression
jonesy won last time and locked him away
jonzy is getting beaten to death
and stops the assault with one single
word geno
i searched the web for answers and the
best i could do was a super mario
character
set to restore peace i know i'm not on
the right lines there but luckily there
was a second part to this clue
and the sisters the sisters according to
greek mythology
fate is destined by the morai aka the
fates
they control everyone and the direction
they take their life
basically telling us our life is not
free it's predetermined predestined
if you've played a god of war game you
will know these as the sisters of
fate these beings weave a tapestry of
destiny mapping out everyone's path
that would mean geno would be the person
in charge of destiny
and the sisters of fate would be those
weaving it into our timelines
this would also tie in perfectly with
the threads of reality pulling the zero
point during the event
strands of time pulling apart i can't
say any of this is true but the train of
thought they sent me on felt pretty
reliable
let's check back here in three chapters
to see if i was onto something
so back to the gameplay during the event
jonesy became a butterfly
the butterfly is a theme running through
the entire fortnite saga since they
watched that scene in the doctor strange
movie in which the butterfly effect was
explained
we came face to face with the butterfly
during the cube event in chapter one
good memories and each time we see one
of these it indicates a ripple in time
something we did in this reality is
affecting others
for example we saw a butterfly as we
dispatched galactus
this lets us know that that event is not
contained to this reality
and during this event jones was
extremely quick to say it wasn't his
fault
for tony stark's actions
what did you do to the zero point it
wasn't me
there was
[Music]
during the event the zero point blooms
and lets out reality surges of power
causing leaks in time to occur that's
why only the autumn areas on the map are
sent
back to the primal age i don't want to
cover time blooms in this video if
that's okay because that subject
can have its own video very soon but
what we do need to note right away
is that we've seen this before during
season three the fade skin was available
and take a look at the back bling
infinite bloom
right in front of our eyes all along you
also may know that i constantly go on
about the convergence theory in fortnite
well look at the name of fades glider
the convergence
follow the butterfly the answers have
been right in front of our eyes all
along
we just didn't know the questions my
mind is blown
and one more to finish let's jump to the
end of the event and the creation of the
spires
have you noticed the rune on top of each
of them remind you of anything
well take your mind back to last season
and the imagined orders
logo look there it is i cannot explain
this in the slightest right now so i
turn this over to you
what did you spot in the event and can
you link them to story did you see an
easter eggs too
i'm adam i'm exhausted thanks for
watching i'll be back in my twitter dms
tomorrow to thank those guys who used
code adamaru personally
anyway i'll see you next time bye